cricket friends let's go as bone bros
i didn't strike you when you said
knocking boots but bone bros
we have to help charles he's devastated
i hate seeing him like this
breakups are cartoony thumbs down they
make people feel faced with x's for the
eyes
what does that even mean the english
language cannot fully capture the depth
and complexity of my thoughts so
i'm incorporating emoji into my speech
to better express myself
winky face oh lord listen this is simple
boyle needs a little rebound nookie
eggplant emoji
rosa you want to get on that don't make
me rip your tongue off
[Applause]
hey charles you pretty excited about
jake being back
yeah it's like when i was a kid and my
grandma came home from the hospital only
better
because jake's not unresponsive every
time you talk i hear that
sound that plays when pac-man dies
charles i'm concerned that you're gonna
tell jake about the incident
nobody can ever know that we had sex all
right i have spent
years cultivating a reputation as
someone who sleeps with
bike messengers or better look
i don't want people finding out about it
either i don't want to be known as the
office [ __ ]
yeah well jake's back and you tell him
everything no i don't
i got aroused last night watching a
nature documentary on bees
i was fine until they went inside the
hive
oh you're right i'm gonna tell him might
not be today
might not be tomorrow it definitely
won't be later than tomorrow so pretty
much today or tomorrow then
neat sweater oh did you tell jake yet
nope really you told him about his own
surprise party mm-hmm
first chance i got but i had tons of
chances to tell him about
what happened six months ago and i
didn't why not i didn't want to hurt
your feelings
no pump the brakes charles cause i'm
terrified of you and what you'll do to
me
oh that's sweet well then
sounds like our nightmare is finally
over
ah what gina
gina i screwed up big time
charles given your daily life
experiences you're gonna have to be more
specific
thank you for coming i wasn't sure if
you'd get my message charles it was kind
of hard to miss
oh god i didn't know what to do you said
we weren't allowed to talk at work now
that we're knocking boots
oh gross listen my ex-wife's throwing an
engagement party this weekend and i was
wondering
if you wanted to go as friends no
charles
just because we have secret shameful sex
does not mean we are friends
pick it friends let's go as bone bros
i didn't strike you when you said
knocking boots but bone bros
i cannot abide
hello gina it's daylight boyle why are
we talking
this is an emergency i've been filming
my fitness routine
with the precinct camera to help improve
my form that's where i got these tree
trunks
but i realized that i left the tape in
the camera and now it's gone
who cares who cares who cares
you probably will
oh well i love that you're trying to
step up your sex game
but strength is not your issue stop
humming
and it does not turn me on when you bend
over and back up into me
did someone check out the camera this
morning yes hitchcock and if he sees it
he will tell
everyone you need to get that damn tape
okay
what the hell new phone who it is you
can't do that in person it's charles
boyle your co-worker what is going on
gina and i are casual lovers oh yeah ew
how long has this been going on we
hooked up once last summer and then the
nightmare started again about a month
ago
ever since then it's been orgasm city oh
yeah ew
ugh gross right guys wait a minute you
lied to me
there was no pizza for one cooking class
tonight you've been lying to me for
weeks
oh i can't tonight i'm teaching inner
city kids to make candles
ooh sorry i'm going through a prenatal
yoga class
no can do going to my adult tumbling
class yes jake those are lies
but the way you looked at me when you
thought i was a gymnast made me wish it
were true
you came in to work with chalk on your
hands boyle
i don't even know you anymore i'm
leaving i just got to get some old case
files first
don't be mad jake you still know me i'm
still
charles i just have four extra sex moves
five
forgot about boy on top ew
damn it charles this is a crisis step
one
termination you and i will never touch
again
damn if i'd known it was our last time i
would have moaned more step two
containment we need to make sure that no
one else finds out
yeah jake won't tell anyone if i ask him
not to i'll handle him
you take care of amy but how to make it
look like an accident i'm not
saying murder just talk to her like a
normal person right even better get her
to tell me all her little secrets then
if she tries anything
we can destroy her it's over between me
and charles
i'm so upset amy when will i ever find a
relationship as perfect as the one you
have with freddy
it's teddy and it's not perfect believe
me
hey i know you only wanted to hang out
last night so you could find out dirt on
me
what uh uh look
you don't have to be worried i will
never tell anyone about you and charles
but honestly it's not as embarrassing as
you think it was shocking
but then i got over it and it seemed
normal
except for seeing how hairless charles's
legs are i mean does he
shave them no he wears really cheap
pants and as far as i can tell he's been
cheap to smooth
yikes imagine that wrapped around you
okay
excuse me i have an announcement to make
can i have everyone's attention please
charles boyle and i had sex what the
hell
gina what are you doing amy was right
people will be shocked and then they'll
get over it and we can move on
at least this way i get to control how
it gets out i'm about to olivia pope
this sich
first off i would like to remind you all
about several notable men from my past
the rock climbing backpacker the
underwear model the guy who looked like
tywin lannister
i bring these men to mind so you can
appreciate this dalliance for what it
was
an outlier i will now take questions how
was the sex
gross the sex was gross or i'm gross
you're gross the sex was adequate
how many times did you do it 16 and a
third don't ask can't explain
i have a question do you have any
regrets
no it was pretty fun
okay charles this is your final exam
we're gonna show you a text
and then two potential responses you
need to tell us which is more
appropriate
amy writes leaving the virgin festival
gina be there in 10 minutes
do you reply i'll be counting down the
seconds
600 599 598 jk
l 597 596 smiley face smiley face
cat smiley face thumbs up or
okay it's a trick question the text
requires no response
charles boyle welcome back to the
nine-nine text change
yes we should call it the nine-nine
party line i'll rename the thread
charles
sorry i'll be better i'll be better
let's give amy a round of applause for
whatever that was
police briefing still in progress and
you did great but let's get serious
people tomorrow is the wedding
my mom is marrying shudder charles's dad
toilet emoji we are gonna be brother and
sister
to think this started with us just going
to town on each other's sexy parts
charles promise me that is not in your
toast
it's not come on man gina as you know
great nana boyle recently passed yes i
watched the live stream of the plug
pulling ceremony
anyway they executed her will guess what
she left me no
her silk bed sheets they were very
special to her she insisted on dying in
them
don't get jealous she left you something
too oh
that's so nice of her and it's a big
jar of brown sludge it smells like death
oh
you got the mother dough ugh did this
come out of her
charles how grossed out should i be
right now no that's the boyle family
sourdough starter it's fetish for 140
years
the bread it births is succulent and
firm
tang for days i hate so many of the
words you just used
charles weirdly you're kind of the
person i'm the closest to here
don't say why because i was your brother
and your lover sorry i just can't
control my tongue around you all right
well
here the boyle family mother don't start
her i'll think of you every time i
handle her oh man
you know i never really understood the
logic behind the two of us
but i love you and i'm gonna miss you
and i miss you too gina
oh that's just my former lover hello
sister
i hate when you say those things back to
back
you